a cut-price cut in color all for 2550
saving Haley Williamson a substantial 51
pounds when the offer appeared on the
daily deals website Groupon 500 people
in the Ipswich area snapped it up in a
flash but it's a gamble for Donna Ghanim
her hair ministry salons will only
receive about half of the money of the
clients come back to the salon from the
500 sold really the daily deal industry
is growing at a rapid rate with new
websites starting up all the time offers
include anything from restaurant meals
to manicures even up and cleaning
they're usually 24-hour deals that end
as the clock strikes midnight tempting
shoppers to click buy and pay up front
before it's too late
in the past three months searches for
Groupon on Google have increased by 78
percent compared to the first quarter of
the year another site LivingSocial saw a
112 percent growth in searches over the
same period but bigger increases still
came from KGB deals with a four hundred
and forty three percent rise in the
number of people hunting them out using
the search engine vanessa church is a
big fan I've used so far so I've
redeemed like a couple so far restaurant
one was really straightforward printed
it out phoning the restaurant and it was
you know it's done just gave them the
voucher and really good service in
everything and yes pretty good but it's
common for businesses to sell so many
deals that they're overwhelmed by
demands with customers struggling to
even get through on the phone to make a
booking and sometimes it proves
impossible to redeem a voucher before
the offer expires the key according to
Haley is to be selective
like as you can actually can see things
and just friends and things but if
you're careful and for the owner it's
already worked out well
Haley's booked in to have her nails and
eyebrows done to the deals on these
sites can be phenomenal there are some
really big headline savings the problem
is deliverability and fulfillment where
we get the complaints is people who sign
up for a 15-pound massage that could
cost eighty quid for a one-off massage a
couple of members of staff failure of an
unbeatable offer can feel too good to
miss but the advice is to make sure the
bargain you're signing up for can live
up to the thrill of the purchase Emma
Birchley Sky News Suffolk